Elly's in Baltimore hi Ellie how are you
I'm great how are you Dave better than I
deserve what's up
so my fiance and I have been together 10
years we have three kids wedding date
has not been set yet we recently
finished financial Financial Peace
University but for the last two months
we've been setting budgets and I just
can't quite get him to stick to it won't
marry you for 10 years can't stick to a
budget I'm shocked
we have about $40,000 in debt total
18,000 of which is in my name it's a
student loan so I guess I'm wondering
what my next step is if I want to follow
the baby steps and he's not ready yet do
I start paying on my snowball first
there's much going on here that I can't
line up with and I don't know how I'm
going to be able to give you really good
advice to bear to be honest with you
okay so here's the thing it is were you
married and calling me with the same
question the answer would be it is
almost impossible I mean I've seen it a
few times but all of our data says one
of the key ingredients to people
building wealth is both spouses being on
the same page and having a goal and
agreeing to sacrifice stay at that goal
together now we have lots of
disagreements all of us about what how
deeply sacrifice what we sacrifice on
and that kind of stuff
okay lots of that kind of happens but
dragging along dead weight and building
wealth called a spouse is almost
statistically impossible we almost never
find it okay
now you're not married so that makes it
even weirder but you got kids and y'all
aren't acting like you're married so I
don't I don't know what to tell you this
is weird I don't know what the it's like
all kinds of problems here so you know
what I would suggest to a married couple
would be that they get if you absolutely
cannot
get your husband to or your wife to get
on the same page with you then it
becomes not a money issue or a financial
piece follow the system issue it becomes
a we can't get a long issue and that
becomes marriage counseling but you
don't want to do marriage counseling
when you're not married right so you
guys got to decide I mean you have to
paint or get off the ladder here you you
know it's it's time to do something if
if I could get my arms around both of
you and be a Papa Dave I would just say
get married get premiered get
pre-marriage counseling post marriage
counseling get married let's decide
we're going to commit to this thing this
thing called marriage this thing called
life this thing called three freakin
kids we're going to commit to all of
this and we're going to commit as a part
of that to getting our financial act
together and you know get in some
financial coaching and if you can't get
it but it sounds like that you guys have
a lot of stuff going on
with commitment in your relationship we
can't commit to a future which is why
you can't stick to a budget the only
reason anyone would limit their spending
and their joy today is to have more joy
tomorrow but if we're not going to be
here tomorrow because we're not
committed then there's no reason to
sacrifice for tomorrow and so that's
where all this is mix here so I would
say you guys need to sit down and get
some good life coaching from someone who
can help you on the marriage pre
marriage post marriage issues and then I
think the budgeting stuff will come
together because once you've decided hey
we're doing life together and you've
been acting like it for quite a while so
I'm not saying you're completely
uncommitted but you know we've been
engaged for a long time you know kind of
thing is you do deal with that stuff and
I think the budget stuff will work
itself out